[Music]
gay people have been seeking the freedom
to marry in the United States since what
we talked about as the dawn of the
modern gay rights movement we usually
date that movements beginning a little
erroneously to Stonewall and the
pushback against police harassment that
was pervasive at the time here in New
York City at the Stonewall Inn in 1969
so within three years of Stonewall there
were major cases brought by couples
seeking the freedom to marry all across
the country percolating through the
courts all the way up and one of them
even reached the United States Supreme
Court in 1972 the Supreme Court in 1972
like all the other courts rubber-stamped
the discrimination throughout those
couples the the courts weren't ready the
conversation hadn't yet happened and the
country wasn't ready well the goal of
Freedom to Marry the goal of our
strategy and the goal that many in our
movement rallied around over these four
plus decades was to get the Supreme
Court to say yes what it had said no to
in 1972 but the strategy said that the
way we're gonna do that is not just by
filing more briefs or leaving it to the
lawyers alone but instead by shaping the
entire climate in which the decision
makers including judges and the justices
were thinking about this in other words
while litigation was the way in which we
were going to deliver the victory in
order for litigation to succeed we
needed to win in the court of public
opinion
in order to win in the court of law my
favorite passage my favorite sentence
came in the case in which we won the
freedom to marry and brought the freedom
to marry to Utah one of the most
conservative states in the country and
the judge in the Utah Freedom to Marry
case wrote it's not the Constitution
that has changed what has changed is our
understanding of what it means to be
lesbian or gay
well that sentence encapsulated the
entire strategy and encapsulated how all
this work by so many different
organizations and millions of people
contributed to delivering a litigation
victory we had to change people's
understanding of who gay people are we
to claim the vocabulary of marriage love
commitment family connection we had to
engage people as well as decision-makers
in the the shared values of treating
others as you'd want to be treated of
seeing the common humanity and
aspirations and dreams of gay people so
we looked consciously for the kinds of
tactics the kinds of ways in which we
could make that persuasion that
conversation that set of conversations
happen one example is that we did not
write people off
we very much looked at who the people
who were not yet with us but who were
reachable what I called the reachable
but not yet reached and how do we most
effectively engage them clearly
conversation we knew would be the engine
of change both this air cover of
political ads and political debate and
news coverage in popular culture but
also the quiet persuasion that was
needed to get people gay and non-gay
people to talk to others around them the
air cover was the public debate and some
of that debate came through battles
attacks from the anti-gay side
discussions in the Legislature's
coverage on the news as well as popular
culture softer presentations of who gay
people are whether through TV shows like
Will & Grace or people coming out like
Ellen DeGeneres but but also all of this
discussion up here that created a
climate that encouraged people to talk
about this that helped frame the
discussion that gave people images but
what closes the deal is not this air
cover it's the ground game the personal
conversations the millions of
conversations around coffee tables and
living rooms and and water coolers and
offices the personal engagement the
one-on-one discussions that gay people
needed to have with the non gay people
in our lives and that we needed non gay
people to be having with each other
in order to talk through what people may
be seeing or hearing up here in the air
cover and so by looking to who you want
to persuade what are there
values what are the commonalities what
are the stories and who are the
messengers and what is the drumbeat and
ways of engaging the people where they
are that's the way you bring over a
slice and you don't need everybody but
you need the necessary enough and that's
what we were able to achieve and if gay
people can go from 27% support for the
freedom to marry which is what it was at
in the 1990s to 63% support that we had
grown by the time we won in the Supreme
Court in 2015 if gay people can do that
surely we can make the kind of progress
we need to get our country back on track
on all kinds of other fronts where we're
starting at a much higher baseline to
begin with clearly some of the elements
of the Freedom to Marry PlayBook are
very relevant for the Democrats they're
very relevant for all the different
causes there is no one cookie cutter
strategy but the PlayBook and the
elements of success I think are very
applicable and adaptable to the other
work at hand for other causes other
organizations other countries other ways
of moving our society forward getting
our country back on track and making a
better world and history tells us
including our own history of winning the
freedom to marry that we can change
things we the people can do it and it's
up to us to do it we have the tools we
have the opportunity we certainly have
the urgency and we have each other